hey Outlander fans I'm Liana Galera with
Entertainment Tonight and I'm joined by
a very special guest right now we have
Outlanders head production designer Gary
steel Gary thank you so much for
welcomed me into lollipop thank you for
coming I'm so thrilled to be here right
now every set that I've been on is just
so phenomenal there's so much attention
to detail and I understand it's because
of you and your amazing crew yes we have
amazing crew 120 people who are very
very talented
patrina took me around the Boston set
and it is so amazing typically how long
does it take to create that in the
middle of one season we'll start doing
sketches and we'll make a model for the
following season that way when we finish
the season we got drawings started and
then we come back we have usually get
four months to get all the major big
sets done for the beginning of filming
now what was your goal in creating the
Boston is that we're basically trying to
show Claire in a whole new world try to
make it look different many different
ways via colors and the furnishings of
course yeah no it's beautiful and I'm
loving all the different blues because
it was something very unique what was
the decision behind that we were looking
at car color samples how it started we'd
found on eBay these different samples of
car colors from the 50s and the 60s and
what kept popping out to me with
different shades of blues and greens and
I was talking to Gina the decorator what
if we try that no matter where we are in
that set you look through and you see
different shades of blue and green and
that's kind of what we end up doing and
another iconic set we are going to be
having in season three is Jamie's cave
there's a lot of detail that goes into
such a small space can you talk about
that yes he's in there a long time we
actually end up building it all on sage
the exterior is out on location but we
built part of the exterior because every
cave that we were going to was too hard
to get a crew of almost 200 people to it
and so we end up finding a place that
worked to get the crew there and then we
built a entrance to a cave like space
what set are you most excited for the
fans to see in season 3 probably the
print shop yeah that's my favorite side
this year do you purposely put in any
little behind-the-scenes secrets into
your set first year we had some things
in Gillis's room upstairs that were a
nod to the future and the
can look for that we were talking about
putting something in the print shop
okay so fans should be looking out for
that response all right I'm excited to
see that perfect well thank you so much
for keeping the different ammonia I was
so excited there are so many great sets
and I know that they're going to look
amazing because of you and your team
[Music]